there are many questions this evening
after a shooting at a city of las vegas
pool happened sunday night at the
pavilion center pool
which is right on alta and pavilion
center the i-team's vanessa murphy now
has the story
there were numerous shots fired here at
the city pool sunday night numerous
shell casings were found here
city staff tell us the pool was rented
out for what was believed to be a family
reunion
but the eye team found it was a party
advertised with general admission
we've got several investigative teams
working this 24 hours a day to bring
this to a resolution
we're still trying to find victims and
witnesses of this crime on eventbrite
there's a banks and spanx 3.0 indoor
pool bash advertised for sunday starting
at 3 pm
the private location only given out
through direct message
tickets 30 dollars in the rules no
verbal or physical
altercations but sources tell the i-team
more than 100 shots were fired
leaving at least one person injured as
of tuesday metro police captain fred
haas reports
no arrests no weapons recovered and no
motive
identified yet as police try to piece
together what happened
he heads summerlin area command and
tells the i-team
metro received no notification ahead of
time
that any party was going to be held here
we have to make sure
these events are safe for not only the
families that are having the events but
for the rest of the community as well
councilwoman victoria seaman says the
person who rented out the pool from the
city of las vegas did it
under false pretenses we take public
safety
very seriously and we are going to get
to the bottom of it
and we're going to find out what
happened so that we can make sure it
doesn't happen again
a now deleted instagram post by the
organizer offered a four hundred dollar
prize for the best
twerker video from the event is
circulating on social media some of it
showing
alcohol which councilwoman seaman says
isn't allowed here at the pool
these are not the type of events that we
would
rent out our spaces too these are for
community
family events very disappointed
now you can see palo verde high school
is next door
now the other way there's a playground
and just across the street
there's a church and homes we talked
with a couple of neighbors over there
they tell us they thought they heard
fireworks for memorial day
we now know that was shots fired
reporting in summerlin vanessa murphy
8 news now thanks vanessa metro police
asking anyone with any information to
please come forward they say more than a
hundred people attended that party
you can remain anonymous you can also
earn a cash reward for any info
that leads to an arrest by calling crime
stoppers there's the number
702-385-5555